es gibt so dinge die gehören einfach
zusammen
pommes und mayo red bull und wodka die
spd und bekämen
das geht nicht aber die cdu und die
jugend also da
da kommen jetzt plötzlich kinder wer
weiß was passiert ja wer weiß was
passiert wäre
könnte ja sein dass junge leute eure
politik scheiße finden ja also das ist
doch eine vermischung von ganz vielen
pseudo fakten genau wo beim tag später
bei 5 millionen klicks da hat er hat
einen punkt getroffen weshalb die union
im elfseitigen pdf wir haben es mal
ausgedruckt dem rieso erklärt dass
verkürzung nicht okay ist
es weiß ja keiner besser als die cdu die
hat die laufzeiten der akw es erst mal
verlängert diese sind nach fukushima
wieder verkürzt hat den sachverhalt die
die union nie verkürzen würde und
kommunikation über videos das ist nicht
der stil der cdu sondern unser stil ist
es auch sich miteinander an einen tisch
zu setzen an einen tisch setzen mit
kritischen jugendlichen ist seit 68
auch wenn die 80er auch nicht stuttgart
grenznähe auch nicht christoph user
upload filter nicht als er neu für die
union deshalb ist es ja so gut dass ein
haufen youtuber nach liegt kann die
union gleich zeigen was sie gelernt hat
die frage stellt sich schon mit blick
auf das thema meinungsmache was sind
eigentlich regeln aus dem analogen
bereich und welche regeln gelten
eigentlich für den digitalen bereich
regeln für meinungsäußerungen jetzt
nicht gleich zensur schreien
das war bestimmt nur unglücklich
formuliert der cdu findet wahlkampagnen
von promis im internet eigentlich durfte
und erst die freie meinungsäußerung
gerade bei parteiveranstaltungen
geschäft kramp karrenbauer dieses recht
besonders
es war kein journalist vor ort wir waren
herren über die bilder wir haben die
nachrichten selbst produziert so jemand
hat doch nichts gegen das grundrecht
seine meinung frei zu äußern und zu
verbreiten aber dass das heutzutage
tatsächlich jeder tun kann jetzt darauf
daraus sind wir nicht vorbereitet
gewesen
ja ja